[Applause]
our next guest fun fact has been
smooched by none other than Harry Styles
maybe we could all vicariously jump in
his body and be him for a minute all
right please welcome the incredible
talented just how he's so everything I
don't know where to begin it's Nick
Kroll
[Applause]
I'm like oh my God
I'm so happy for your life thank you I
mean how is being a dad I mean what's
it's such a bummer no
has anyone ever come on the show and
done that by the way I regret it drew
every day I regret it no but it's it's
been it has been amazing it's like a
true like true gift we have a very he's
a really beautiful good boy and um at at
this moment I'm like oh there's this is
the best thing I've ever done and I feel
so excited
and
do you are you a ham with your kids
because I am such a ham with my kids for
sure and I do John Hamm for the kids all
the time no I but I definitely I mean
I'm I'm desperate for his approval and I
I do the voices for him and I'll do a
voice uh and I'll sort of he'll probably
like my voice can you give us
no no I'll do like I'll give him an Elmo
or you know and he doesn't even know who
Elmo is but I'll just be trying to him
and I'll be like oh how are you doing
and oh my God can you imagine what it's
like to be necros kid and he'll he he
literally will be like and as soon as I
do a voice like that he goes hi
but he thinks he's like someone else has
walked into the room which is comedy in
itself he's your straight man thank you
that's what I tell him every day
um but he's no it's it's really there's
no joy like hearing the laughter of your
child uh it really is like a truly
um no I I was reading about your wife
Lily yes and you guys met on a dating
app yes okay this is so hopeful it is
she's uh oh she's so beautiful she's
beautiful she's a landscape designer and
a Botanical installation artist that's
so sexy yeah she does like truly amazing
work uh and
um and we met because as you know it's
like when you come when you're when you
have been in an industry for a certain
amount of time you end up feeling like
you've met everyone and your world
becomes smaller and smaller and I got on
the this app to sort of try to meet
people that were outside of my
particular circles and and I ended up
meeting Lily
um and we she I think she messaged me on
like New Year's Eve like I don't know
2018 uh and then we chatted for a while
and then finally met a month later and
uh and here we are and then we now we
have uh we're married and have a child
and so uh it's beautiful it's really
great yeah now Nick has got this
brilliant new stand-up special it is
hilarious and Incredibly personal we
have a clip take a look I am wearing
silk boxer shorts
businessman on vacation in Hong Kong
those slide right on
Lizzy looks over at me and she is now
eye to eye
with my bald little cashew
is horrified
Jenny the girl who pants to me is
mortified
and I am now a comedian what was it
about this special that did you have a
North star of what you wanted this to be
this particular project I hadn't done a
stand-up special in like over a decade
and I you know I've done a lot more like
voices and character stuff and I really
wanted to do a stand-up special that
felt much more personal it was actually
Lily my my wife when she was my
girlfriend she was like why don't you do
an hour why don't you how to do a
special I was like Ah that's for the
other that's for all my friends who are
like their stand-ups and and then I sort
of was like you know what I'm gonna do
it and I I took a a note from what we
had been doing on on Big Mouth which is
this animated show that I make which is
very personal and and largely
autobiographical and much more
vulnerable than anything I'd ever done
before and so I tried to take that to my
stand-up special and sort of really talk
about where I am in my life and then so
many things in my life unfolded while I
was making it like the lockdown and
getting married and having a child and
all of that sort of informed the
stand-up and so the hours of much more
piece of I I hope first and foremost
funny but but also very kind of honest
for where I am in my life it's really
great yeah we have to go to a quick
commercial break will you take us to
break as any character you would ever
want to do I just love hearing you do
your voice okay I could do uh maybe
Gunter from yeah sorry okay don't go
anywhere we are heading back in time to
believe a little bit of the seventh
grade and so stick around
[Music]
foreign